[Music]
In other words, I was a virgin until I was 30,
so I was able to use the magic of reading people's minds, and by chance I
found out that a man in the company liked me.So it was
n't just a delusion.What do you
like about this dull person?
There's still an element of becoming.I can't
help it.I wonder if you'll thank me with your body next time.It's
too much for me, so I can't hold it.Please
let me touch that cat.  I don't mind if you give it to me.It's
kind of you.I'm glad that's the case.If you'd
like, could you please come again?It's fine.Yes, you're
surprisingly nice.Ando-san,
thank you very much.I
love you.Maybe this is
Shiba.  I've
lived for 30 years and have no experience in love, so I have no idea
what to do even if I understand the other person's feelings.I think it's
better to think about how you feel about the other person than what to do.I like it.  I'm not sorry for what
happened, but I can't help but feel the
voice of Kurosawa's heart that I heard every time I touched it.When I was able to
hear the voice of my heart through magic, I
thought, why does he have such power?  I
felt like I had been touched by Kurosawa's heart.
As I kept touching Kurosawa's heart, I realized that it was the first time for that person.
If it was me, it would be the first time for me. I
can't stop thinking about Kurosawa.
[Music]
to
Ah